And who is Donald Trump
to be lecturing anyone
on the treatment of women?
I mean, between Rosie O'Donnell
and Megyn Kelly,
I wouldn't exactly say
he's woke on feminism.
Well, here to explain himself,
please welcome Donald Trump.
(applause and cheering)
Your viewers thank you
for having me, Larry.
(laughter)
By the way, happy Mother's Day
to all of the mothers out there,
except the unbelievably mean,
nasty enabler ones.
Okay, see, see,
that's what I'm...
That's... that is
completely uncalled for.
So, listen, why are you blaming
Hillary Clinton
for what her husband did?
Larry, this election
is a clear choice
between someone
who treats women with class
-(laughter)
-and those nasty...
horrible Clintons.
I mean, they're really nasty.
I mean, they're terrible people.
I said that even back
when I gave them lots of money.
-I mean, I gave them a lot
of money. -Okay. All right.
Okay, how can you say that?
I don't know how that's
coming out of your mouth.
Look, you're
on your third marriage,
and in your book, you even
bragged about infidelities.
Because when your mistresses are
as unbelievably hot as mine...
(laughter, groaning, shouting)
And they really are hot.
I mean, unbelievable.
I mean...
You don't keep that to yourself.
I'm not selfish.
This is what
I'm talking about! See?
I-I don't know how you can say
you're better at treating women
than Hillary when you say
horrible things like this.
-Excuse me, excuse me.
-What? What?
I treat my wives horribly.
Okay? There's a difference.
(laughter, shouting, groaning)
But when they're not my wives,
I treat them like queens.
I mean, every year
for Christmas--
and I do mean Christmas,
not holidays--
-What...
-my mistresses and exes
get a box of Trump steaks...
-(laughter)
-and a beautiful off-brand
flat-screen TV.
They're spoiled,
they're spoiled.
I'm sure they appreciate it.
Look, but let's get back
to Hillary.
How is she an enabler?
Isn't she the victim
of her husband's infidelity?
I'll tell you who
the real victims are here--
Bill's mistresses.
I mean, do they get steaks?
I don't think so.
-Okay?
-(laughter)
And I could have gotten him
a bulk discount.
Believe me,
I'm very good at business.
-Okay?
-Okay. This is insane.
Nobody wants a bulk discount
on your steaks, all right?
And how can bringing all this up
be a good election strategy?
You've said horrible things
about every woman
you've come across. Everyone.
Not true, Larry.
My daughter, Ivanka, okay?
(loud groaning, shouting)
I mean, it's like
God created an angel,
an angel to have sex with.
-I mean, beautiful, beautiful.
-Oh, that's... -(jeering)
Of course, we all know
I can't have sex with her,
obviously, because, you know,
I'm running for president.
(laughter)
Okay, that is
completely disgusting.
Donald Trump, everybody.
We'll be right back.